[Music]
hello everyone welcome
hello science enthusiasts from all over
the place here we see you
and you see us this is great um it's a
pleasure to host today time travel and
climate
changing the past to fix the future or
maybe the other way around which is an
event hosted by sapia the science advice
for policy
by european academies as part of the
berlin science week as you know
my name is ac koppens i am a strategist
host moderator working at the
intersection of technology and creative
content and this is why i'm here with
you today to animate this conversation
with our guests
and i'm going to present them in a
second
we are streaming here live from the
museum furniture kunda berlin berlin's
natural history museum
and we have you online audience and we
have you who made uh he made it in the
saturday morning welcome here it's great
to see you
and um we have also our guests on site
this is great
so maybe let me tell you a little bit
more about sapir so that you know like
what is this so as we're saying science
advice for policy by european academies
bringing together more than 100
academies from all across europe
and sapia is part of the scientific
advice mechanism which role is to
provide scientific advice to inform the
decision-making of the european
commissioners
and the scientific advice mechanism
delivering our advice on how to make
europe's transition to a sustainable
energy system a reality for this the
sapia asked a group of experts to write
a report which reviews all the
scientific evidence
on the topic and peter lundt who are
here is one of the speakers and he was
the co-chair of that group
the sapir report on the other hand was
then used by the european commission's
group of chief
scientific advisors to write a
scientific opinion
and our other speakers neboshia
nakichenovis is one of these chief
scientific advisors
whoa i'm very honored to be here with
you two here today
and um so these two documents maybe we
can even have the links in the in the
chat or something there are two
documents the evidence review report and
the scientific opinion
and um this is where we based on our
events on so to speak on both documents
and they both go under the same title a
systemic approach to the energy
transition in europe so that's it for
the context so that our audiences know
why you're here today i mean you know
why you're here today because you wanted
to go into a time capsule i know that
we're going to get there in a second
and let me tell you i'm going to
structure this discussion today so first
of all we're going to have these i know
you want to go to the time machine so
first we will go to the time machine
and explore the imaginary the future and
the past we will spend
something like 20 minutes on
and after that we will go to the reality
and the solutions and this is where you
can ask really your question so in the
first part we will more have playful
interaction with you polls and etc
for those of you who are online
please
if you want to comment you have to go
through your gmail account you have to
be logged in to make the comments
otherwise you can take part to the polls
on youtube you know that's not a problem
for you here well
raise your hands i will see you you you
don't need so much tech to do it this is
more sustainable
and um we will do it so
first part more polls maybe a couple of
questions we will see second part
reality and solutions we will go into
the technology and into society and we
will explore and you will have the
opportunity to ask our speakers directly
and we will take more time 25 minutes
for the technology 25 minutes of the
society okay
so this is how we're going to structure
the the discussion today but now i mean
at least you want to know a little bit
more about the speakers so i turn to you
first peterland welcome a pleasure to
have you here peter is professor on
advanced energy system at alto
university in finland
and he works on future energy questions
and technologies having an interest in
multidisciplinary approaches
he has chaired the
advisory group energy of the euro
european commission sorry the energy
steering panel of the european academy
science advisory council and as i was
saying before the separate working group
on europe's energy transition
thank you this is really great that you
made it here today peter and um
neborisha nakichenovic
he told me i may call him naki to make
it easier and i will do that
naki you are the deputy chair of the
group of chief scientific advisors of
the european commissions that i said
before you said i need not mention this
but i want to mention that he's the
director of the world in 2050. i thought
it could be interesting because we're
going to travel with the time machine
you know so this guy is an expert for
sure because well you know he's working
on it because it is um it's a it's a
global research initiative right in
support of successful implementation of
the united nations 2030 agenda so you
see 2030 2050 we're in 2021 we are
traveling already right
and uh just also something to to to add
you are acting director general of the
international institute for applied
system analysis great and welcome to
your next small correction former oh
former yes sorry
i'm traveling in time too i'm sorry for
that
so you know it now we have the evidence
review sapia peter and we have the
scientific opinion advice of naki and um
okay it's not my style to put people
into the box because they go beyond
these labels okay
so welcome to all of you and uh let's
have a look now how did we get into such
a mess
do we want to go back or forth bring
some evidence from the past um or change
the future and bring the technology back
and um
yes i think it would be really nice to
know how you are there but um what do
you think the audience are we're gonna
make a little poll and i want to check
how fast the technology is
so can we have a poll now
and um i'm going to ask you
audience online to put this
in your
youtube thing if you had a time machine
would you go in the past or in the
future
and i'm going to ask you here
immediately
what what about you who wants to go to
the past let's count
past
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
oh that's only two people want you to go
to the future
hold on let me ask the question who
wants to go to the future
one there is someone who doesn't know
where they want to go
right you want to stay in the present
right
okay that's fine with us stay with us
we'll go to you we'll get you covered
okay so incredible majority of people
here on location who want to go to the
past
okay so this is wonderful the youtubers
are not there yet so we are between us
okay well that's really interesting i
would like to
have you um first maybe peter to reflect
from your perspective and your
experience what do you think why do they
want to go to the past what do you think
i think it's a very good question and i
think you can answer this question in
many ways uh and and uh if we think
about humans uh we live in time which
always goes forward
this is
how it goes but if you think about
learning
how we learn we learn by looking back to
the past what happened
so so both are important and and in in a
way when you go back to the past
you you already know what to do in a way
and you could fix things
also i think uh going looking at the
past
maybe we gave more time and we know that
the climate change there's not much time
so if we go to the future maybe we can't
catch what we should catch so going back
in time gives you more time also to fix
the problems or the feeling of security
because we think to know the path better
yeah yeah
future may be tricky in the sense i mean
if you go too far away to the future
maybe it's really
too pessimistic so so uh you're on the
you know about what happened in the past
there's no risks
yes if you go to the future there may be
a risk that everything went wrong
okay or
you bring something which wouldn't work
in our time
uh anyway my heart my soul ticks for the
future because that's what i do in my
work
you would go there right yeah it's the
future energy systems
i would have some bits and bolts which i
would need and i could fix some things
now so that's why as a scientist but i
recognize really the importance to
by by the a trade-off between this and i
fully understand that people think past
is important i i think it's very very
rational good good choice okay good so
before we go to nike just
who of you is a scientist here
okay
who would like to be a scientist
okay well
this is shy
well i hope you will change your mind
after this discussion at any case so
nikki what do you think whether chose
the past or what's your point of view
from your perspective yeah thank you i i
broadly agree with what peter just said
but let me first say that i'm delighted
to be here in this session and in
particular in this museum
and
i have exceedingly fond memories of the
natural history museum here in berlin
during the last decade i served on the
german government's council on global
change and at the beginning the offices
were not ready so the museum was kind
enough to offer us the premises here for
our meetings so i spent quite a lot of
time here and i think that brings me to
to the time machine in some ways we can
see this museum as a time machine we see
the history
we see the history we see big
disruptions we see dying of species the
evolutionary process and i think as
peter said you know the history i think
teaches us what might happen in the
future i also work on the future i work
on the scenarios and pathways of what
might happen and how we can make you
know achieve that but i would argue that
history is exceedingly important and in
some extent let me just add this not to
take too much time in some extent
past is also not completely certain
we always discover new things about the
past and you know so the past itself is
an evolutionary process and i think it
helps us understand a little bit better
where we might go into the future and
how we might steer that i mean at the
end of the day it's all of us who will
make the future happen together yes so
you would go to the future
uh that's a tough question actually i
really don't know you can make it yeah
yeah i really don't know i would
my first preference would be actually go
to go back to 1970s or 1990s this is
when i started working and at that time
we already had the science we were quite
certain of what would happen with
climate and many other systems even the
pandemic was on the books then we knew
that there would be at some point i mean
collectively the scientific community
that's at some point a pandemic might
come so all of the big problems were
already perceived in the 70s and the 90s
there was the notion of a precautionary
principle
and i would like to go there to see you
know how we could change it not to lose
30 40 50 years that we lost in tackling
this problem
and the next choice would be 20 30 50.
i'm gonna ask the audience in a minute
like where do they want to go exactly
because past and future are really like
very general and i see that our own
audience is now there hello audience
nice to see you you made it welcome to
the museum and we are between dinosaurs
and great scientists about the future to
fix
the energy problems we might have for
the climate and um we have another
audience so join us welcome and i see
that the audience on site is also
growing this is nice you made it it's a
very limited space here um but you all
very nicely
split with the meters of distance so
that's good welcome so we go further and
um i would like to know for those who um
i think we do not have do we have oh
yeah okay so if we can have the poll and
do it again for the audience online we
know these guys here um they want to go
to the past so i would love to know
maybe the online audience is more
digital and maybe they want to go to the
future we're going to have this so
please take part to the polls that i can
see and um i'm going to go on with you
here
and see
for
we have new person so who wants to go to
the future let's see if we have new
people wanting to go to the future who
of you wants to go to the future
no one
okay one one one
oh sorry okay oh okay good good good so
um and tell me very briefly like
what part of the future do you want to
visit like
five to fifty years
50 200 or above 100 years
five to fifty
one
two
okay fifty two hundred
oh okay no now we want no people want to
travel and then
over a hundred years
yes okay we don't be shy yeah that's
good we have a couple of people so they
want to introduce you that's good okay
so um
how do you foresee the future both of
you starting with peter maybe
yeah if i just relate to the time how
far we should go i would prefer a time
which would still be relevant for our
case here
in in the sense that if we go very very
far away
it may be a very fancy technology but
can we use it
uh there's always a another question is
is the misuse of technologies
and i would say that that the in a way
how we would bring technology from the
future is also related to our kind of
moral ethical standing of the humanity
and this is very tricky if we think that
we would have a black hole we bring a
black hole from the future
it would be enough for germany to
provide all this energy for one year
with just 100 kilogram of material
but it's a huge bomb as well could that
be misused so these questions become
it's not any more technology but it
comes through the essence of humanity
how we deal with technology so i would
prefer
let's say a a a
shorter distance where i could bring
some
immediate to scaling up for instance to
clean technologies or doing the things
but almost what we have uh because of
this there's so tricky questions that
would come up with the future yes
and see i just had a look uh the online
audience was 50 50 with past and future
so they are much more into the future
than than you guys i mean i don't want
to make a competition between the online
and offline audience right but we're
going to observe these differences
that's interesting we'd like to say
something about the future
absolutely yeah i mean i i
let me just what peter just said let me
phrase it what he said in my own words i
think this can be seen as a paradox of
technology in our thinking about the
future that many of these things can be
exceedingly positive for our society but
they can be also negative
and very often technology is both the
solution and the problem and this is why
i would also argue that going to let's
say 2050 in the future that's beyond my
lifetime so it would be very interesting
to see what happens thereafter
precisely because that's roughly the
time span when our societies if you look
back in the past when our societies
really change fundamentally you know if
you go 50 years back you know that's
beginning of the jet age that's the
beginning of the internet and sometimes
but the point is that some some of the
some of the systems and of lifestyles
also change over the 30 30 period
but there are more incremental changes
for example the best example is the
mobile phone everybody in the world has
a mobile phone it's an incredible
success both in the global north and
global south and that took 30 years it
started in 1990 took 30 years so if you
look forward 30 years that's 2050 we can
achieve a lot and maybe
another observation as many of you know
right now there is a conference of the
parties on the climate convention in
glasgow there have been some really i
think encouraging commitments to go
toward net zero 2050 in the emissions or
thereafter and for that we need
herculean efforts over the next 30 years
that's interesting because the the only
audience wants to go much further in the
future distant years fifty percent over
a hundred years okay whereas uh 5200 is
almost 16 and near like five to 50 is 33
that's really interesting i hope they
get inspired by what you're saying right
yeah yeah but that could also reflect
our our kind of a
human nature that we hope for a saver
or or something that saves these very
great problems that we have and and this
is very often i think in humanity if you
look on where we have high times and
climate change and this is is one of the
grand challenges maybe the grand
challenge
and in that sense you hope maybe for a
silver bullet or something which would
solve this
and unfortunately very often we have to
do the work that there's nothing that
comes from outside which does
work that we should do
we need to make decisions everybody
needs to do something and in that sense
we can't outsource maybe these questions
to technology
maybe there is in the future something
you never know this is also how science
work i mean we haven't invented
everything and i think in the future
this for sure must be very interesting
things which i don't know anybody know
yes me neither but but anyway i i think
in a way that uh as a human yeah let's
let's be prepared to do ourselves also
in climate change something yes nikki
yes yeah just a brief comment i i think
there is also a lot uh that speaks for
going further into the future even
though my preference would be 2050 but
going beyond 100 years also i think has
a very strong logic one of the reasons
is for example the climate problem even
if we go down to net zero by 2050
emissions which is the objective we will
not stabilize the climate in over 100
years
it takes a long time i think that is
probably true with the digital
revolution too it's going to
fundamentally change our society like
the mobile phone and internet have that
will probably also take many many
decades so i think they're good good
reasons for going in the future in
addition to what peter said that we all
somehow have this desirable
inspirational goal of of being you know
in a sustainable world that's just and
equitable and fair to everybody and
saves the nature at the same time
i mean
let me just ask the audience very
quickly about the
don't lose it about
because they okay let's let's say they
go to the future like how could a time
machine help us reinvent the energy
system okay you want to go to the future
so you want to see
oh hold on sorry a time machine help us
it doesn't matter in our future or past
let's have the pool what does it bring
us see the future problems
to act now
that would be the number one so it means
like see the reality of the future learn
about all this and of course the
consequences so that we know what to do
now
second bring back future technologies
or maybe others
other things so what do you think here
um on site i think we have more people
by the way do we have more scientists
now than before
scientists raise your hands
no okay they all want to become
scientists but okay so
see the future problems to act now who
wants that
see the future problems to act now
yeah i know you wanted to go to the past
but don't worry about the future so okay
okay well that's very shy answer two
six seven so okay bring back future
technologies
yeah they are more technology-oriented
things okay good and other comments
we're gonna have the results of this
poll in a second
and um
and then i want to know because i really
want to to see what um what they think
about the past they wanted all to go to
the past and i want to what you said
nakia want to go back also and ask them
when when exactly but first we wait for
the results of this
thing so we we see it's um
it's not a magic there there is no great
majority for
you you don't know right
that's the thing
i mean who knows what what would you do
would you bring back your technologies
yourself or would you just simply like
check what's happening and work on the
consequences already today
yeah my honest answer is you know i
don't think that's not possible in
reality even if he could go into the
future it's it's simply not possible so
i think it's a nice you know it's a nice
concept to think about it but i would
argue
that we have problems today we don't
need to go to the future i mean we know
what the problems are we have the
pandemic the no real tragedy of the
pandemic
even though science has been great we
have vaccinations but not everybody
wants to be vaccinated right
you know we have the climate problem
lots of pledges to have you know the
climate neutrality by 2050 and avoid the
major crisis and yet we don't know
whether we will change our lifestyles
whether we will really behave in
accordance to that and maybe we go into
those details thirdly i what i already
mentioned i think digital revolution is
also has huge dangers on privacy but
enormous potential benefits for the
society as we already see today during
the pandemic i mean we have digital
audience yes that this is quite
something new it's happening as we are
speaking so i would say if you just
mentioned those three problems we have
enough to do today and i think we have
to solve this today and the future
this is the problem of going into the
future future is indeterminate has many
branching points what would you bring to
the present so i would argue let's try
to think how to resolve these problems
concretely in a practical way and choose
the future that's desirable to us that's
that's a good one i see the audience
wants to learn about the future problems
and saw them now and i see the comments
are coming now the idea of the future is
part of escapism and know it no it's
starting no no it's going to be fun okay
good but peter please yeah i think both
both in a way past and future are so
intriguing and i think about again the
question go to the past
in the sense that uh i think it would
matter indeed and and uh but but the
timing is important where
the past should we go
if you go to the wrong point
nobody cares nobody understands maybe
and and we i think we have enough
information now that we know slightly
about the future what will happen if we
don't act for instance now properly with
the climate change
but i think the time point going to pass
is a point where we have strong social
cohesion
and with social cohesion i mean that we
we act as as a mankind not as
nationalists or nations we act as a
mankind
and we're going to find those time
points i think one is very often to use
catastrophes we find those like after
the war where the whole europe was
destroyed
most of the world were destroyed the
strong
cohesion between population to do
something for the future
so i would go back to that 1945.
yes let it's the perfect moment not to
ask where do you want to go back sorry
yes no no no that's perfect you make my
transition i will continue peter you can
you can moderate with me next time this
is fantastic okay so let's do the poll
online and offline let's see the
questions so um audiences i see that you
are going on comment let's concentrate
on the poll now when and how did it go
all wrong where would you go back to fix
it so
first
5000 bc not before corona before
christmas money enters the stage
second industrial revolution
well 1660 1840 right
invention of electricity 1819
invention of cars
1886
invasion of airplanes
1903
invention of the internet
and all the following you know like
smartphones and etc coming up 83.
so you have all this i want to know now
oh do you have enough here no we we we
miss here the internet so okay well i
will i will do it to you so okay online
you go on you're busy i do offline so
money enter the stage who wants to go
back then
start of capitalism no okay good
industrial revolution
one okay
oh sorry who please raise one really
like yeah yeah yeah one two three four
even four okay five okay who says more
good
um that was industrial revolution five
invention of electricity
one two three four yeah it's convenient
right yeah okay four
good um inventions of invention of cars
one two three okay this is surprising
airplanes
one two three four
five six okay airplane six okay and the
internet
the internet no
no one
that's really interesting okay i want to
know now online
tell us and online if you didn't have
the internet please put it in the
comments so that we know if you are also
for or against or whenever not for it
it's not being
for it or against it's just to go back
and fix maybe what happened back then so
we have oh oh wow okay it's only seven
but uh industry revolutions 85 percent
okay so it's really interesting to see
we have a a different perspectives here
okay so um yeah so let's examine the the
the responses before we go now to the
reality and the solution so um is it
realistic to actually
expect to fix something from the past
naki you want to start with this
question well you know depends what you
mean by that
in the practical sense yes
i i think you know history does not
repeat itself we know that but certain
patterns do repeat and from that point
of view it is i think very instructional
i think what the majority of people
thinks to go back to the beginning of
the industrial revolution to understand
how all of that unfolded you know we
shouldn't forget that industrial
revolution brought benefits to many to
billions people today but has also left
billions behind industrial revolution is
a story of great successes but it's also
a story of famines and major disasters
you know oppression of the working
people and so on but i think one of the
greatest achievements of humanity in the
industrial revolution was abolishment of
the slavery that followed and so we can
think of such big
libera liberation justice movements
today for the future so from that point
of view it's interesting but let me just
make one comment
i would argue that the invention itself
is not critical
uh what you have up there what is this
critical seeing in the online chat yes i
would argue what's critical is actually
the diffusion how do we adopt new things
new institutions new technologies new
lifestyles and that takes time and this
is why it's important to think about the
future because it will take time
so i think you know just one example
cars it took about 30 years to replace
horses by cars yes so it might take 30
years to replace you know internal
engine
combustion vehicles by electric vehicles
so it takes time so this is exactly what
layla was saying in the chat wonderful
peter yeah yeah i agree fully that i
mean the list that we see here on the
screen are technical disruptions these
are technologies
but the consequences are societal
these these are so
important innovations that they they
exploded the whole society they they
created kind of new type of thinking
they they brought even democracy if you
think about industrial revolution it's a
time of the enlightenment
where the human being for the first time
gets a value you think about the uh
french philosophers
and and i think that may have been a
time point when this big transition
happens the subtle transition how do we
brought the institutions already then
that may correct the faults that comes i
mean we didn't have any corrective uh
kind of
ways
to to solve the problems that our
technologies would do
at that time of enlightenment where
people were really open
to really reform the whole planet they
say that we can now actually start the
planet again
and that was the time point had to put
the institutions that give the feedback
correct make these corrections i think
maybe we could have saved some of the
problems that we have here but i agree
it's it's not the technology question
but it's everything else what comes
along that okay
so now let's go back to the sad reality
we don't have a time machine or maybe
it's not sad maybe it's good we don't
have a tag machine i'm not gonna adjust
this um so let's go maybe into the the
part into the the reality and um the
solution
right so how would that work and um i
think that i was saying for those of you
who came a little bit later also online
or offline um we will structure the
discussion in two parts the first part
will be more about the technologies the
the real technology and please focus
your questions on the technology
and the second part will be on society
more it doesn't mean it's not related
obviously but we want to have these
questions more organized into that way
and um
um
you you made me the the comment peter to
say well technology is made by humans so
and by society and it is you had a
wonderful comment on this you remember
you were saying like
you cannot really separate the two right
yeah i mean technology is part of the
human
uh
let's say
intelligence yes about the creativity
that humans have
and and why we why did we invent
technologies is basically to improve
our living conditions
which is not bad
but but again as naki said i mean
there's consequences and and this is
important to take responsibility not
just to use technology but we have to be
responsible and and this is the question
is that we are very creative
and and that's something that will not
disappear before the human can mankind
disappears and that's the force that i
think can solve these problems that
we're talking about even today
so let us see this is the part where
i stop asking a little bit more maybe i
want to give you the stage much more
online or also here offline and this is
the one which you can ask your question
so don't be shy i know we have two very
impressive scientists here on stage
really bright minds but
we all have bright minds and uh we want
to know and um asking is um never stupid
asking is always good so there are no
stupid questions
don't be shy and ask the questions where
you're very interested it is a unique
opportunity to be here for you uh who
are here in the museum with us it's a
unique opportunity unique encounter so
use it and for you online we don't
forget you we see you uh here so and i
get your questions
um
here on my phone at the same time so you
are totally with us so ask your
questions also i will make the the best
i can uh to check the questions we have
online so
to introduce this discussion maybe to
make it a little bit easier so we said
we'd like we do not have a time machine
and which technologies
will help us
to uh save the future so to make a
better future um what are outstanding
examples you can you can talk about
different um
technologies and batteries and nuclear
and whatever whatever comes up you can
ask them because
they will know but maybe to start the
conversation like
do we have a question now in case we
have a question now
okay
this is saturday morning but it is a
quarter to 11 right you are
kicking right
good good and uh online um just check oh
we have a question this is great oh no
we have a comment from matthew randovel
by growing in the past could we
massively scale its nuclear
it nuclear nuclear in the 90s and also
invest more in renewables
yeah i mean that's a comment
technology um
technology nuclear technology
any questions about nuclear technology
on this
hold on i would like uh to ask you to
stand up please so that we can see you
the camera can see you and you get a
disinfected microphone
yeah i don't know is it okay with the
mask can you yes please articulate
welfare sorry uh so i was actually
wondering i don't know how technologies
you guys are but what do you think was
the state of renewable in the 70s
basically when we could have studied to
tackle climate change
and um would it have been possible to
have the scale up that we have nowadays
or would have we have had to rely on
another technology basically if we had
known in this i mean if the public had
known in the 70s like it wasn't hadn't
been hidden by the
oil industry could we have scaled up
renewables as fast as we're doing today
or would we have had to rely on another
clean technology like nuclear for
example i guess but maybe you have other
in mind that were available back then
yes thanks to ask your question clearly
not too fast and really have a question
yeah okay so who wants to take it first
sure
yeah well
technology evolution is is is complex it
comes technologies come like waves and
they goes like waves and very often when
a new energy technology kind of pops up
you need to have the basic science
already done there you need the kind of
all around kind of a fertile ground when
the where the technology comes out and
in that sense i think we may perhaps
slightly speed up some things no
question
but this kind of fundamental change that
we would bring let's say
some of our technology 100 years back
there's not the fertile ground there's
not enough knowledge the science to to
do that so so unfortunately we are very
often kind of locked into something
but but this question is is maybe also
could we speed the lock out we are
locked in into technology because of the
boundary conditions because we are not
able to do anything else
and what happened is at some point the
new technologies may be mature enough to
take off
and take
on the the technologies of the old and
that's where the the
lock out becomes important let off from
the old and this is i think one of
dilemma that some technologies does keep
on ongoing even though we would have the
better technologies to go on that's part
of more the social behavior side as well
so i think in that sense when the
technology is ripe we could do something
quicker but the fundamental problem is
is always
with the question that everything else
around
science infrastructures techno need to
be supporting technologies we need to be
there that we can
make make the change but but again it
looks like that
we we have this kind of a we call path
dependencies
that the history
goes into the future maybe too long and
we could actually cut off it by by
police stations
i would like to also take a crack at
this i think that's an important
question i mean arguably today we are at
crossroads the world is at the
crossroads i mean it's we are at the
junction
we have a possibility of going in a
sustainable direction but we also have a
possibility of continuing the current
trends that i think will lead us to a
dead end in some ways it would be a bad
road to take i think 70s that was the
question was a similar situation 50
years ago and that's when i started my
professional life so i remember very
well all of these the the debates about
nuclear about the renewables
and
so as peter said i mean this is a very
complex issue but let me say the fall
and it's an evolutionary process so with
ups and downs and so on experimentation
failure success and so on this is why it
takes time but on renewables you know
the challenge then in 1973 we have the
energy crisis serious energy crisis even
more energy price explosions than we
have today 79 was the culmination of
that and it was clear that renewables
would be a part of the solution at that
time there was absolutely no doubt i
think there was a strong consensus with
some you know with some exceptions but
what would have been required for
renewables to contribute more back then
would have been determined and
sustainable investments and we didn't
have that you know one thing that we
know about technological evolution is
that the more you invest in technology
the better it becomes the cheaper it
becomes right and that really only
happened over the last two decades with
renewables with the substantive with the
new institutional arrangements with
quite lots of investment but at the same
time let me say that the peak of
investments was in 2017 not today so the
peak of investments is behind us i mean
it's almost a paradox and the good news
is that the developing countries are
investing quite a lot in the meantime in
renewables and there was a question
about nuclear back then in the 70s you
know there were so-called safe nuclear
reactor designs that did not make it
they were not selected at the end of the
day
the nuclear costs have exploded in the
meantime
so you know i think
nuclear might be still a solution in
many many of the countries but we will
need new technological breakthroughs to
make nuclear safe and acceptable and
most important economically viable
absolutely there is an ongoing
discussion on nuclear energy in in
france right now two weeks ago i think
the president has been announcing that
there was a wishing to have more
research on new prototypes of small
nuclear nuclear reactors that would be
much smaller and not that complicated
and not that dangerous so the in france
it's a very hot discussion all the time
because we rely on nuclear allergy a lot
there yeah if i mean this is a very
controversial issue
exceedingly controversial but you know
in our scientific opinion that's based
on the evidence review report of sepea
to the commission
we argue in one of the recommendations
that this diversity in europe can be
also seen as a richness not just as a
controversial issue but as a rich man
because there will be different options
and different solutions might work in
different parts of europe that could be
an idea of having a resilient uh
approach on the way forward
but i hope that we will abandon what
doesn't work and invest massively in
what works so
that's how i see this crossroads that i
was talking about
we have a question also from online i
just want to check before the person
precise the question maybe any other
question from the um offline audience
here so yes we have one this is great i
wait for uh oh ho ho-ho to uh
please uh precise your alienation
question and i will check it afterwards
so first i'll take you so please stand
up and
welcome and thank you for your question
uh thank you so much for
speaking with us today my questions
about dual use technologies which you
were talking about before and i'm just
curious to hear more about what you
think scientists and regulators roles
might be in terms of
development but at the same time
regulation of them so because everything
has potential for good and and
risk what do you see as these different
stakeholders roles
peter well
this is a very good question in
particular if we think about the
magnitude of the change that we need now
in energy for instance and going to
sustainable energy
uh so so so we we move from a a
technological change actually to a
societal change
most of our legislation regulation that
we typically have in our countries
they support the present technology all
they say the past technologies already
we needed regulation and laws
that that the old technologies could
work and now when we bring the new
technologies which may have quite
different characteristics uh are not
like the old technologies so our old
regulation and outlaws may not work for
that they may be even a barrier to
against the new technologies
so in that sense we need to update
our institutions i mean with
institutions legislation regulation
standards norms
so that the new technologies can come in
and and therefore
the religious legislative part of of the
transition becomes very very important i
think europe is proceeding to the green
deal now to that that point where we
really start to
form our legislation so that that
becomes optimal for the new technologies
to come in
uh
regulation will be always important uh
in some sense i mean the free market
most likely will not take care we need
regulation
uh
even though we would have carbon pricing
which is important mechanism there's
still kind of black spots where that
doesn't work so we need a regulation
there too
uh
so there's a combination we have
technologies we have the regulation and
policies and and of course the social
behavior which we may talk slightly
later on so this is a kind of a
combination of of elements which need to
work together as as a whole
yeah in the scientific opinion but also
in the super evidence review report
there is a strong argument made
that this needs to be people-centered
process that means it needs to be
inclusive that means that you know ngos
all of the stakeholders have to be
involved but we also shouldn't forget
public and private sector stakeholders
at the end of the day it's the private
sector that invests so we have to make
sure that the investment's going to the
right direction this is why we argue
very strongly that each that should be
the case um and um but there are two or
three components to that i think to to
make that viable uh one component is
that we are talking i'm afraid we are
talking about really disruptive change
if you are going to achieve the european
green deal it's not going to be smooth
it's going to be
disruptive that means some people will
be left behind we already see today with
the explosion of energy prices that
there are many energy pours in europe
maybe on the order of 30 perhaps even 50
million people
we need a safety net for them that means
as the carbon price increases that peter
mentioned this is very likely otherwise
we are not going to steer ourselves in
the right direction the revenue needs to
be neutral in the sense that it should
be used to support those who are the
risk of energy poverty but should be
also used to support some of these
innovations we are talking about so in
that sense it has to be really inclusive
process and let me just conclude this
thought by saying one of the motivations
for me saying that i would like to go 50
years back in 70s when i started working
on these issues
is because i wish so strong that we in
the 70s we had the movement like fridays
for future scientists for future why
didn't you start it back then well yeah
why did we not start it it's a good
question why i mean you know there were
movements but they were not they did not
diffuse they were not that accepted they
were you know they were not
didn't become a part of ourselves and um
so you know finally i think we need to
ask ourselves in this you know inclusive
people-centered process that i hope will
happen
how will we
as is it individuals and collectively
have new norms new culture yes that's
consistent with european green deal yeah
so now we have tons of questions coming
up so we need to be we can be a little
bit faster a bit quicker
i don't forget you uh dear offline
audience but uh we have the online
understands coming strong uh and i'm
gonna take the question i was excluding
just before so maybe a short answer
anything to say about technology and
alienation so perhaps the question might
mean something like if you have
technological development without making
sure everyone is on board do we leave
parts of society behind feeling
eliminated um if so this would this
would be a problem right i i think this
is a very central question in the future
is that when we develop technologies we
we have to have the human component uh
it's for instance acceptability do
people accept the technology in the past
nobody asked you they just brought the
technologies but nowadays it has to be
more technologies needs to be developed
in interaction with the humans and and i
think you are the best experts to judge
is this suitable this technology yes so
it means that from very top
we need to come more to the bottom-up
type of approaches okay so so you you
have to co-combine
scientifically social science and
technology much more as as like you said
that it's really people-centered
that brings also to the just question of
justice is which is so important this
transition with speaking but it should
not be unjust
everybody has to
be kept on board
not just in europe i mean europe is less
than 10 of the emissions globally 90 is
elsewhere 60 of the emissions are in
asia in countries which are struggling
together by living standard so we
need also to think more globally but
justice globally and maybe rich nations
like european union need to be part of
that development to help the less
favored countries to go more sustainable
okay
yeah quicker yeah we have so many
questions coming now you know this
explains actually why the diffusion
process takes such a long time you you
have to bring everybody on board
sometimes things don't get accepted
there are failures when they're accepted
everybody needs to be on board and i
think a good example we have today is
the great scientific success of having
vaccination against kovid but many
people don't want to vaccinate them so
we don't know it's indeterminate we
don't know what will happen will we win
the pandemic because everybody will
eventually be infected or because
everybody will be eventually protected
okay we don't know we will have this
discussion in a year probably so note it
or something but no like um i see that
uh the person has a question about
alienation as a comment on this which is
bringing the question in another
direction we're going to keep it at the
transition to society so stay tuned i
have another question what technology do
you technologies
do you think are ripe
in quotes to break through and change
the world in the next 30 years that's a
good question i want to know too yeah
well
if
as i like very much technologies and
work with that
there are very interesting technologies
uh coming on based on scientific
discoveries in particular materials and
other fields
uh which are let's say ripe into
laboratories that need soon to be
brought on the market
and one is is is to combine uh solar
energy and fuel production we call it
solar fuels
where we use which are actually
uh coping with a circular economy using
materials which are abundant
uh
everybody have those technologies
and and and and basically it's about
combining
air
water
sun
and super catalysts
so with those elements what we have free
everywhere air water sun and then we
need the magic ingredients so to say
we can make
fuels we can make chemicals fertilizers
everything what society needs and it's
totally closed cycle circular economy
and
and that would be the super technology
which i would go to the future to look
on would that come we there's a few
things we do it already laboratories and
it's it in the next 30 years as the
question is i think if we speed that
technology and i know that helmholtz in
germany doing much work in this
this could be a breakthrough technology
again it may take time let's be patient
as as like i said this the diffusion
process is along but there's a lot of
hope as well to have this kind of
people's technology technology for the
people and and which would be harmless
so to say for everybody in the
environment okay like here
first of all i would encourage everybody
to look at the two reports because we
we describe the portfolio of
technologies both what can be done
immediately and what's breakthrough in
ten years or so uh and you know i think
we have the link in the in the i hope of
the reports we'll have the link in the
comments again for those who came a
little bit later yes so it's clear you
know zero carbon energy sources like
renewables um electrification of the
world we need to go electric uh but i
think and peter has mentioned those so i
will not repeat it but you know i think
there is another important area since we
talk about inclusiveness is what are we
going to as consumers to do i think
that's going to be the biggest issue you
know will we
replace our oil and natural gas heating
with heat pumps will be all drive
electric cars or even better we'll use
public transport and bicycles and
walking just to mention couple of
examples will we have hydrogen aircraft
and hydrogen ships in the future this is
all a part of a portfolio these are more
disruptive technologies probably to
start entering the market in about 10
years and then i think the big unknown
is what the digital revolution will do i
think this is a real big thing you know
one could even say you know it has
started with the pandemic we are going
into the virtual world you know enhanced
reality through internet and other
digital technologies but on going
towards zero emissions that's going to
be a very important part of the equation
uh at the same time working with some
dangers like privacy misinformation and
so on so it's a long story i just wanted
to mention that this what is very close
to us technologies that are closest to
us are quite important and those are the
ones that will actually steer the nature
of the energy system other systems like
recycling you know you cannot have
circular economy if we don't recycle
ourselves it's simply not possible but
we have to protect the nature we have to
reserve the materials we have to use
you know let's say urban mining and the
materials that are in the system in
order to decouple ourselves
from environmental negative
environmental impacts we published a
unep report earlier this year that we
called making peace with nature that's
what we making peace so we have to make
peace with ourselves and we have to make
peace with the nature that's a very good
one very good title i think what is
important that like you said that the
magnitude of the change it's like the
the the industrial revolution in the
18th century
and and that's that's a challenge we
need it there's not one single silly
bullet
though i like this solar fuels but
there's many technologies which you need
together and we we have technologies and
then we need to glue between that the
glue maybe
energy storage digitalization
and this architecture of energy will
change so fundamentally and that makes
the huge societal also change that we
have this is good because you introduced
the next question you were a really
great moderator so what's a past
technology we stopped using or that is
underdeveloped but can be a better
option eco-friendly is there any past
technology we stop using or which is
still underdeveloped
yeah so i mean you know let me
share something that i think you're all
aware and you mentioned that the cars
came in 1900 1903 let's say don't forget
at that time time we had very
environmentally friendly cars we had
electric cars and it was not even clear
whether the internal combustion will
build the game or electricity and so we
are returning a century later to the
same technology that has been stopped in
the embryonic footsteps of innovation it
is just as an example yes of course
renewable energy was even in three
industrial times uh you know we
shouldn't forget that hunters and
gatherers and early agricultural
neolithic societies were quite
sustainable from the point of view of
energy we use the sun flow the river
flow animal
yes human so this needs to come back
bicycle is human muscle power
that's right that's right and that's a
very good energy so um someone is saying
we are told energy storage is needed to
tackle the unpredictability of solar and
wind in wind energy
is this entirely true no we need the
scientist here is this entirely true or
with better predicting techniques and
better mechanism to sell electricity
yeah so
unpredictable unpredictability of solar
and wind energy and energy storage is it
true
well based on the
scientific evidence report that's
developed
actually this question needs to reform
in the sense that what we need is
flexibility
not
just energy storage but that may be part
of demand response where digitalization
comes from that we if the demand and
supply energy is not in balance we could
do some small tricks uh just just reduce
the demand for one hour half an hour
that is in balance so if we don't have
the wind we could slightly smooth that
we may have also kind of a smart
charging of electric vehicles this
edification which nike talked about that
we we electrify not just the electric
sector but we use electricity from solar
and wind also for mobility for heating
houses actually most of the energy that
we need in germany for instance is for
heating more than 60 of the energy goes
for heating that's where we could use
electricity
and heat pumps very effectively so this
kind of sector coupling may be one way
actually to go around the question of
mismatch
no solar solar and but again going
slightly forward in time
we see that energy storage definitely
will become important and in particular
now when the uh transportation
is is getting electrified typically the
batteries in your cars will will uh
they live for about 10 years after 10
years the battery capacity has come down
to 70 so you wouldn't use in a car
but these batteries are excellent still
for energy storage for solar and wind
and and we expect and that was also
mentioned in the saper report that by
2035 2030 we could have kind of a second
life batteries from the cars coming
putting in the solar and wind which
represents about 10 15 of the peak
demand of the whole europe
so so this is also how the logistics
will work
uh uh and so we wouldn't need just
building batteries for solar and wind
but just use the scrap from the the
electric vehicles use sector coupling
demand side response a magnitude of
things that we already have
which needs organizational uh issues how
we organize how the regulation works
there's no incentives nowadays we don't
have proper regulation that gives a
market signal
if we have those in place the tech this
uh
a huge family of flexibility
technologies regulation market signals
i don't see a problem as a scientist
in in this mismatch question
so you you you were saying a bit earlier
because i just need to check also like
they are doing strong here online so if
you have questions you know make
yourself visible i will have a look i
see that there is a question coming i
just need to ask another last question
here um
actually
no you are first
okay first of all my question is about
nuclear
do you think that without disaster such
as chernobyl like you know how rbmk
reactors like in the past they have been
disasters
um
if those big disasters in history never
happen do you think that we could
that basically nuclear nuclear
technology could have
gotten very big in the world and we
could
very very easily reach renew renewable
energy
in our current state right now and
second of all my question is more about
the risk of new technologies with energy
especially
for example um let's say
black hole technologies right
at what point do you think is
our new technologies especially for like
for energy is
uh worth the risk because like
oh
at what basically at one point is one
technology worth the risk for its
benefits for the world because um
as you know even nuclear technology has
its risk so
um yeah
so what i just want to make a a note
because we we the interesting part in
your question also is talking about the
disasters it never happened we never if
you notice in our discussion we already
consider the society dimensionals of
this so i like this very much because i
want to move also into the society
in the next question so please sorry so
my my specific response to to this
important question is that a stylized
fact of of of evolution of new
technologies and systems is that at the
beginning you have very large diversity
i just mentioned before the beginning we
had steam cars electric cars and so on
you have very large diversity and there
is a selection mechanism to us through
you know customers selection mechanism
and part of that selection mechanism is
also a response to disasters and
accidents when railways came first
everybody was scared of airways i mean
it was
unprecedented speed that the railways
operated many people thought it would be
dangerous to our health
this turned out to be unwarranted but
when hinderberg went up it it was the
end of the airships yes um and so
chernobyl was a very important negative
event in the evolution of nuclear
technologies and and so
what i'm trying to say is accidents will
happen that's the nature of
technological change it is important
that we have regulatory mechanisms and
proper social response to improve the
technology and if it turns out that it's
a dead end to abandon it because we also
have limited resources but diversity is
very important because none of us know
whether
you're an expert or you're a member of a
general public or an ngo no but none of
us know what will be successful in the
future but we know roughly the direction
it needs to be zero zero emissions it
needs to be sustainable and so on so the
direction we know we have aspirational
goals but exactly how to get there we
don't understand but we know what is
needed so we need to work on this yes we
have a portfolio of technologies that
know that are needed but how that will
exactly evolve is an issue of policies
regulatory mechanisms and our personal
choice yes peter i think what is very
important also to recognize are let's
say for instance how nations or
companies deal with nuclear or any
technology depends on how you frame how
do you frame that technology
by framing i mean i mean is against
which kind of criteria would you
evaluate the technology and how to
weight these criteria so if we just
think for instance nuclear that
let's say that the only criteria would
be co2 emissions
other criteria doesn't matter so that
means even even even using the free
running rivers in europe for energy
production would be important or using
nuclear if you start to add then other
criterias like cost store or
environment etc it means means and how
we weight those it means that in some
countries you may say that well we can't
use this technology we don't
find it it's optimal and we use other
technologies so how you frame how you
assess the technologies against a range
of criteria which criteria do take on
board
that's a political question as well in
some countries you don't take this
criteria in other countries you take the
whole list and how you weight those that
will determine very often also the
political decisions that we have seen in
the past and definitely will influence
also the decisions in the future what we
have
i think
of course the question sustainability is
important technologies need to be
sustainable circle economy is is
important etc so we have a lot of
important criterias but keep in mind
that that that
different countries may look on a
different way a different way on this
criteria how to choose and they may wait
some country may say this is not an
important criteria others says it's
important so it's a very complex issue
as you said this is not simple
well we need also this controversy like
what is right what is wrong and there is
actually no right now there are options
and we need to discuss these right this
this is a question it's it's and that's
why the humans the people need to be in
that society
you need to give the signals you decide
it's not politicians
or companies you decide
uh so far maybe you have been off from
the picture so to say but we need to
bring people back to the center of
policies and and then you determine then
you take responsibility it's your choice
this is a very important uh comment
thank you so much peter i think there
was a second question here at the back
um michael it's not more of a question
but more of a thought or a dilemma that
i have um this is more related to uh
like us saying that innovation is
something that that we strive for maybe
in the future uh but if you look at it i
mean you also mentioned this that uh 60
of the emission is actually coming from
asia in general right because all these
companies are kind of manufacturing
things and like uh electronic components
let's say in china or also in in other
parts of the of the of the continent
itself now
that is something that the innovation is
is reaped uh is is done in in let's say
in europe and america right so that
innovation is coming with a price this
is why let's say the countries are kind
of generating so much of uh carbon
emission in this case so i'm i'm more
interested to understand your thought
process like from the scientific
prospect like when we talk about
innovation how does that kind of like
also work with the with the society in
general right now because it's it's
it is taking us two steps forward but
also bringing us a step back
yeah so
you know i think when you look at the
innovation process
especially toward net zero carbon uh one
can say that there is you know
you know innovation pool and innovation
push push comes from the scientific
communities from the research science
innovation and pool comes from the
society
now i think it is for for the pool it's
very important to have a vision
long-term vision accompanied with the
short-term action plans and some of you
might be aware that we in europe have
something like that it's called fit for
55 package that was legislated back in
june the reason why it's called
55 fits for 55 is that it foresees by
2030 a 55
reduction in the emissions in europe and
by 2050 carbon neutrality this is
exceedingly important because it's a
legislation it's not just hypothetical
promise now at the conference of the
parties in glasgow
you have seen in the news many of you us
is clearly committed to that already as
well with the biden administration
china has committed to carbon neutrality
by 2060 japan by 2050 russia by 2050 and
now the big news is india by 2070. so
you know there are some reasons to be
optimistic but maybe as a part of
response to your question
so we have all of these promises and
pledges
but now we need a plan and i hope that
our two reports are part of that plan i
would not call it central planning
definitely not but something like a road
map how to get from here there and in
particular what to do in the short term
and just to illustrate because i know
i'm aware of the lateness of time let me
just make one sentence to illustrate how
important that is the nobel prize winner
kuznets in one talk in vienna a few
years ago he said
not having a plan is also a plan but not
a good one so we better work
collectively on a good plan that's very
good excellent peter you're taking this
yeah i think the question about
innovation all in all is extremely
important as we know that somebody has
once said that about 80 percent of our
welfare comes from innovation
and i think the emerging economies i
don't like the word
emerging economies because it makes us
so centric here
in europe uh but many countries like in
asia we what it would be important is to
strengthen their innovation system
uh there's a lot of talent in africa in
asia in latin america and so on which is
unused
to to use that potential that also for
innovations
which are driven by by the needs of
these countries
uh i could imagine that wind energy and
solar would even look slightly different
actually if going through the technology
based on on the needs of these countries
so strengthening the system
their capabilities to to come along
would be very important
very important signal from from the
reports that we've done is also that the
new technologies will create job
opportunities
we need jobs people need work
but and that that's in a way enhances
the whole societies
uh in that sense uh i think we need to
in some way have a feeling that we need
to move from european
let's say western world-centric thinking
to much more global to understand that
the climate change is not a problem here
in germany or finland where i come from
it's a global problem a global problem
is a global solution and it needs
breaching between countries now we see
much isolation these kind of superpowers
becoming isolated
we would be much more to bridge them and
also to bridge to the questions that we
have in emerging economies that is the
challenge
that we unite more globally this is
great because you make the transition to
the next question which is even if we
need to think about solutions globally
is it possible to adapt each solution to
every political climatic and social
context
yeah i would say
yes and no i mean there is there is no
unique so you know general purpose
technologies
and use many of the end use technologies
we discussed from the heat pump to the
photovoltaic cells to electric vehicles
electric buses
electric public transport and so on they
are applicable almost everywhere that
kind of universal technologies then
infrastructure we need electric
infrastructures we talked about storage
before
hydrogen might become an important
source carrier of energy as well as a
storage so these are generic
but local content will be fundamentally
different and i've mentioned before i
think that's part of the richness and
the resilience the you know some
countries have hydropowers other
countries might have nuclear in country
where i live nuclear is
forbidden by constitution so we will not
see it
only across our borders not in austria
in austria so
there will be regional solutions local
solution i think we shouldn't just even
think at a country level we have to
think about community level
and frankly we have to think about the
family level as well you know i wish
that some of these issues we are
discussing here are also a subject at
the dinner table when the family meets
on the weekend or whatever i think we
need to develop as i said before culture
and the new norms
about how to adopt these new systems how
they can become an internal part of
ourselves and it has to be inclusive and
universal process but i think it's not
going to be homogeneous there's no doubt
some things will be similar that i
mentioned others will be very content
specific let me just give you an example
urban areas will be fundamentally
different from the countryside there is
absolutely no doubt you need different
measures and you know tropical countries
we will need different and have
different resources than the nordic
countries where the the the sentence uh
the claim think global acts local
clusters you need both you need bottom
up
and the top down we need
top-down vision and goals and road maps
i hope but we need locally specific
action
that also supports entrepreneurial
activities supports the peace with the
nature as i said at all levels so we
need both diversity is the answer
yeah i i i think what like you said it
is really the way to go look no question
and indeed our cultural differences are
there which means to respect i mean in
in and in that sense the technologies
need adoption to the local conditions
but i would be interested to see also
more technologies coming from from the
non-european countries in a way
and and have the the let's say the
creative potential
of these wonderful countries
uh to be part of that and bring
solutions which we may not have because
of our more siloed thinking as we do
very often just to see some new new
progress for instance digital
technologies digitalization uh where you
just look on the bits and and you make
kind of artificial intelligence etc
there's a range of uh very complex areas
but i think a more kind of a global
outreach and global input may be very
interesting but indeed
uh think global act local that's the way
it
go
okay so this is also what i heard a
while ago so i have two questions we
which are more also
into the societal dimensions the first
one is who will pay
for an effective transition
well i guess all of us right yeah yeah
any further thoughts on this yeah i
think very often we hope that this is
the neighbor who pays
but i think it's important now to keep
in mind that everybody needs to pay and
here comes the question about the just
transition
if i'm a well-doing person
in a way i would need to change my
lifestyle i just pay the carbon tax or
whatever but if you're not doing well
you you're a poor person you can't
afford and that hits that new regulation
it's the most the weakest into society
and that's where is the big question
it's a moral ethical question we come to
the essence of all philosophy is all
religions is that the stronger need to
take more responsibility than the weaker
and this i think is the essence in the
whole climate change
without being religious or whatever but
but is the way that those who have more
need to be more active
and in our societies i think it's going
other way around sometimes when we look
how the richness is concentrating
so those who have more you need to be
more responsible and this is the point
yes this goes hand in hand and it's not
gonna make the transition without
without that doesn't i i don't believe
that we can't make a transition if it's
not just so we come to those basic
cornerstones what we call humanity and
that's something that we need to
reinvent it's in inside us everybody
knows that but we need to live up to
that more yeah
so for me the metaphor pay is perhaps
not the best
i would say we need to invest in our
future we need to do that collectively
and it's clear invest
invest rather than pay for the following
reason many of the things that we have
been talking about today during the last
half an hour hour and a half but also
the objectives of the un 2030 agenda we
did 17 sustainable goals the european
green deal agenda and so on all of them
have elements of change disruptive
change
that will bring long-term benefits for
health for our life and so on so this is
why we have to see it as an investment
and another huge multiple benefit is
that many of these technologies once you
have invested in them like renewables
like efficiency they have extremely
small operating costs compared to the
fossil energies just an example the same
thing in the food sector if you start
stop throwing food away if you invest in
the healthier food system will be all
better and the nature would be much
better so that's point number one we are
investing in the future point number two
it's really important to protect those
who are the risk of being left behind
every fundamental disruptive change
means there will be at least for a while
losers and winners and people who are at
risk need to be protected to the social
network so part of the invest
investments i think needs to go in this
just an agri equitable dimension
otherwise we are not going to have the
inclusive process we talked about you
know even people who are opposed to some
of these ideas need to be protected and
eventually i think we will find a a
socially acceptable solution but these
two components in my view are very
important investing in the future and
protecting those who
are at the risk of being left behind it
has to be inclusive for everybody
i think it's important to understand
that
the society as a whole
can afford the change
and it's a good investment that's not
like you said good investment in the
future you get a payoff
you get a better future
but but the the problem is that the the
society is is not homogeneous
and that's why we need this mechanism to
see that everybody is on board
as i make uh have lectures in my
university of the future of energy we
sometimes calculate how much would it
cost
for each one to make the change let's
tomorrow change the world and zero
carbon
it would cost you about
per person per day per person per day
one cup of coffee
so one cappuccino less a day
and that's done
then we look bird wide what does it mean
one cup of cappuccino for me it means
for me better health no question but
that's not a money problem but let's
take take a farmer in africa it's more
than half of his daily living
so how on earth could a poor farmer in
asia and africa be able to invest so
that's why we need to act as a society
the whole society can afford well
and we don't even observe that money
so it's also an important mindset
and to understand this is an investment
that we need to do and everybody will
gain it's a win-win for everybody
okay
we
checking if we have another question
here we have another question i still
keep the one of uh oh ho hoho for later
yes
here in the middle the young lady with a
pink mask
is it pink right
it is yes uh thank you um i have a
question connecting to this point of i
guess uh
diversity of
people around the world but also
incentive structures and i think dr
lundy brought this up before which is if
we're functioning with such short-term
and incentive structures so for the
corporate stakeholders on the scale of
quarters or even political groups
administrations change how do we build
systems towards long-term change that
are one just for that global
global population but also resilient to
changes on those short-term scales
because the incentives
aren't long-term
um yeah
i think this is a good question as as as
everybody knows the
the let's say the time scale of thinking
of politicians is is about the next
election and that's it
and and that's why i think it's very
important that we have this kind of
meetings like the corp 26 in glasgow
where the nations not the politicians
but nations they commit themselves for a
long-term plan that we have a framework
that's is why it's important that this
climate change mitigation goes into the
law of the country which is not changed
every second year or third year
so there has to be more fundamental kind
of let's say instruments i think
and and in case of finland we for
instance we will have a law that
enforces any government to move
forward carbon neutrality and i think
many other countries do
so so so that
making the the let's say the uh
mechanism framework
uh irrespective of the politicians who
come and go and may have personal
interest is important
this is a very very simple a simple
answer to a very good uh complex
question but i think those two elements
have the global framework which enforces
everybody
i mean when your neighbor does something
neighbor country i mean
most likely you will not do something so
the more we get to the to the paris
agreement
countries
the more more it will push forward but
then you need to embed this into your
local legislation and the law is a quite
strong measure i think yeah i also see
two dimensions so this incredibly
complex challenge that you
formed as a question i think one
dimension is this long-term vis-a-vis
short term
and
there is no doubt that we need an
inclusive
universal long-term vision we have to
agree on where we want to go and then in
the short term think about what are the
steps to go in the right direction of
achieving those goals so i think we need
short-term road maps that are flexible
adaptable that would all hopefully lead
to the long-term goals and not block
that future but the second dimension i
think is what we discussed before is the
diversity it's diversity what what needs
to be common to all of us and what you
know what should be diverse or what
should be allowed to be diverse just to
give you an example so there's no
misunderstanding you know people were
afraid that globalization would lead to
huge homogeneization but it did not
necessarily do that think about we have
restaurants of all sorts of parts of the
world and cultures we eat food from
india we would eat food from japan not
just from europe in europe and vice
versa so diversity is not inconsistent
with the common vision and goals and the
common short-term change and i hope that
that's going to be in many facets of our
life that we can prevent preserve our
richness yet have a common vision and
goal that is implemented in the short
term so those two dimensions i think are
important okay
so
um i have a very last question because
unfortunately the time has been crazily
uh uh fast and i want to go talking
about short term long term et cetera and
now going up to the question i had the
beginning for about society
the question about technology and
alienation was meant in a way like tech
depriving the right to think i was
observing people playing with their
phones here maybe you took notes i don't
know if you checked your mails i mean i
was also typing here but i was typing
questions um so
alienating not to seeing not to be there
not to be you know like on top of things
or
animal nation is
being prevented to think
properly what's your take on that one
before we take the final poll
peter or me who goes first both of you
you can decide yeah yeah all right becky
go on first i'll go first
you know i i don't see that negatively
to be honest i i you know we talked
about the risks of many of these changes
we are talking about you know i think
the reason why change also takes a long
time until it becomes pervasive
is that we all
have to become comfortable with it you
know there is an inherent resistance in
all of us against the unknown it's
natural it's perfectly natural and
and i think that helps that helps
improve
the innovation
avoid the risks that we talk about make
it socially acceptable to everybody the
the trouble is and that would be my
concluding thought the trouble is
that we are likely to run out of time so
in some sense time is the most precious
resource because these processes take a
long time and i think this this
skepticism and opposition to change has
a positive role but it also has that
negative role that it doesn't allow us
to
do the big transformation that's
required towards sustainability in the
time that might be needed i mean we have
only 30 years in some ways so time is
precious ah pressure yes you're right
peter yeah i think we as a human beings
we are careful with change because in
prehistorical times very often change
may be a question of existence even so
that is something which is in our case
always slightly resisting any anything
change uh meetings chocolate or whatever
this is very difficult okay i shouldn't
hit
change is difficult uh but but i think
very often it's important society but we
think these big changes you have to have
some sort of leading figures countries
to show the way this is why how our
societies work it may be you individuals
countries companies that show the way
that yes we can do it and by the way
this works well it doesn't cost so much
and and you have a better
feeling about this exactly and in that
sense i i think it's it's again up to us
we get individuals standing up showing
and taking the lead that brings the big
masses it's very often in history if you
look on is some individuals that come
look on the enlightenment in the 18th
century a few
individuals had changed the whole
mindset so i would call for you
individuals people to in a way take the
lead that's the people-centric policies
and i think that is what actually aligns
everybody it's a common goal wonderful
okay that's a great final words before
we go to the final poll so online
audience get ready and you hear we're
going to count uh uh the fingers here
would we okay after all this discussion
we saw time is essential right so would
we want a time machine really now after
the discussion
and two possibilities here
uh
maybe yes because it's too late so
things are going so bad it's ready to
change past now without time travel we
need this or maybe no because we have
hope we are more positive we see here
two quite positive people uh i didn't
tell my personal opinion on this by the
way but okay so maybe no we have hope
because there are so many positive
things to come out of this experience
and if we can manage it we will manage
it we will manage redistribution of
wealth future sustainability so maybe
yes or maybe no you you say i didn't put
yes or no maybe yes rather yes maybe no
i don't know so who is for yes
yes
it's too late
one two three four okay well okay
so um maybe no so do we have any people
maybe no
i want to see that it is really like
yeah it's a vast majority i would say at
least like 80 90 percent so let's have a
look at online in a second
yes we will yet it's too late otherwise
maybe we can still fix things right so
go on online
and see if you have the same message
here
otherwise i take the time now to oh we
know maybe we don't we can still fix
things
that's interesting we have uh yeah quite
a similar uh uh proportion like 66 well
two-thirds
yeah well okay well i'm not a scientist
okay so i'm not going to count exactly
but it gives a a good solution and um
nobody will get a 71 oh it's still
moving
it's still moving 71. say see okay good
we have one a voice more so i hope you
had a good time with the time capsule
here and explore what we could do if i
recap
what the bright might say i don't go
into the technological detail because i
take from this conversation we are
responsible we have it into our hands
right
um
we need to work on a just society more
just society we need to work also on
this diversity and inclusiveness because
this goes hand-in-hand with uh the
innovation and a better revolution for
the energy to change so to speak
and um time is the most precious
resource
so
even if we need to be careful with
change or we are careful with change we
need to take the lead i hope this is the
invitation for not only today the next
days and for life thank you very much to
all of you who have been here with us
thanks to the tech team in the
background thanks to sapia for inviting
us for this wonderful discussion it has
been a honor and a privilege for me to
lead this discussion with you guys
fantastic thank you and i know you met
30 years ago you're correct yeah so
that's also trying to travel here that's
part of the time machine yes exactly so
now you can believe in time machine
actually science is the time machine
maybe sometimes malfunction but it's
there and surpeia is part of that time
machine okay that's great thank you so
much thank you very much and have a
great day
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you